hey leute es wieder eure mal wanne mit
5000 abonnenten
heute geht es mal über das thema frauen
denn ich habe das gefühl manche männer
verstehen uns frauen gar nicht und da
möchte ich heute ein paar antworten
geben
viel spaß frauen die von immer gleich an
zu heulen das stimmt gar nicht
frauen brauchen wir viel zu lange um
sich anzuziehen
gut wir können uns schwer entscheiden
aber wenn wir abends mit euch weg gehen
heißt es viel arbeit für uns die frauen
single welt da draußen ist hart und
gemein freut euch lieber dass wir uns so
eine mühe für euch machen ständig sind
sie nur am lästern wir leicester
nichtachtung es folgt nun ein billiger
facebook spruch wir stellen nur fest
frauen wollen nur machos wenn man nett
zu den ist dann wird man gleich in die
prävention gesteckt wenn es die nicht
reichte meiner frenzel zu sein
dann hättest du es vielleicht am anfang
deutlicher machen sollen und man landet
in der fremde und nicht weil man zu nett
ist sondern wer hätte es gedacht
vielleicht weil du nicht mein typ ist
wie kann man nur so schlecht gelaunt
sein wenn man sich ein fingernagel ab
bricht natürlich sind wir dann angepasst
wenn einer abbricht haben so viel mühe
und zeit in diese nägel investiert damit
sie so hübsch und lang sind und wenn
dann eine absicht ist einfach scheiße
immer glauben sie dass wir anderen
frauen hinterher gucken ja klar glauben
wir dass wir tun sie selbst aber da tut
uns doch den gefallen gemacht wie wir
unauffällig und wenn man mal ein film
guckt müssen sie immer dazwischen seelen
ach so wenn wir beim film mal kurze
frage haben oder über diese oder jene
situation sprechen wollen dann ist es
ein problem aber habt ihr euch mal beim
zocken beobachtet ich meine man muss
doch nicht jedes mal kommentieren wenn
man jemanden umgebracht hatte das ist
nämlich ein problem
ich hoffe euch das video gefallen wenn
ja gibt einen daumen nach oben
dann die uns das nächste mal
jetzt muss auch der mama denken tun